hailey Baldwin opens up about her  rumored boyfriend Justin Bieber I love  that  after going on vacation together over  the holidays and sharing this steamy  pick the Biebs got candid about the  model in marches issue of GQ calling her  quote someone I really love et spoke  with Haley on Wednesday night at the  amfar gala in New York where she  returned the same affection what do you  love about Justin Emily you know he's  really funny we have a good time  together he's just really sweet he's a  good kid he's a good heart and I love  him does your dad like him that's the  big question both of my parents like him  a lot you need that parental approval  Farrah for old school yep so I hope he  comes up with something romantic for  Valentine's Day ah yeah i just want food  you